so this question of whether or not
there's generational differences I think
it the broad brush level I think that
all human groups and in the research
shows anthropological research going
back to pre-industrial times we actually
all want the same kind of leader but the
nuances are different depending on the
generation what we want it turns out is
we want a boss who is competent and not
selfish or benevolent so in the book I
described this as a boss who is good at
performance getting performance out of
people training them supporting them and
in doing their job well and supports
dignity and respect and so the idea of
having competence and benevolence or
confidence and compassion you can see
that all through research going way back
those are the people who tend to rise to
the leadership positions in
pre-industrial tribes and those are the
people who we also want as our leaders
so at the most abstract level that's who
that's who we want to lead us as human
beings but but at different times the
question of what somebody who's got your
back or is compassionate I think that
gets reinterpreted so so one of the
issues that the Millennials have which
for example my parents my parents didn't
have and even my generation to a lesser
extent is that first of all that they
want both men and women want to be more
involved in raising their kids if they
have kids
so in that case having a job where
you're working 75 hours a week doesn't
work out too well for everyone and
another thing that's happened with the
Millennials that's different than their
parents or even to some extent my
generation and I definitely see this at
Stanford with my students is boy did I
see it the last couple of years is is in
my family and other families you'd see
that somebody would work for a large
corporation for years and would be okay
but what's happened to their parents is
well they've learned and they always say
the man it's funny they've learned not
to trust the man that the man's going to
screw them in the end and in fact that's
the new employment contract so it always
sort of amazes me when I see executives
from big corporations and they say I
don't know why they don't trust me well
you've been layoffs are at an all-time
high and in fact there's evidence it
isn't just the economic times that
layoffs are becoming a more
increasingly an increasingly sort of
frequent response to economic troubles
they happen quicker and they happen
deeper and then there there's fewer
organizations with pension plan
essentially the employment contract has
changed so so my perspective on the
Millennials is no wonder you act that
way you you've been taught that the
man's going to screw you or sometimes
the woman if you're working for somebody
like Meg Whitman or something or Carly
Fiorina who actually laid off lots of
people Meg didn't lay off very many
people so so so in some ways the
Millennials are acting completely
rational and it and therefore I guess
the definition of a competent and
compassionate boss changes it's it's
somebody who is skilled at I'm giving
you the skills and abilities and
connections you need to continue
throughout your career even after they
fire you so so I thought do you think
that relationship has changed some and I
guess that the definition of a nice boss
is nastier than it used to be you can
give me notice nice and still do pretty
nasty things to people
so the notion is in a business book
author I should probably make the
argument should buy my book and all your
problems are solved but anybody who
tells you that by taking this class or
reading my book you will magically
become a good boss is lying to you but
but the analogy I use is a little bit
like medicine that that what you want is
a doctor who both has a lot of
experience and the doctor who actually
knows what the latest research is
because experience is sort of a
dangerous teacher in some ways it's good
to have the craft knowledge but you also
need to sort of leaven that with with
the mistakes that many other people have
made and more systematic evidence and
and so I think you sort of need the
one-two punch of both of them and one
thing that really does strike me is that
some of the most effective and
impressive bosses and managers to me are
people who are hungry to get as much
experience as possible so I think that's
true for the Millennials anybody else
that takes a job you want to have as
much different sort of management
experience as possible and also hungry
to sort of if you will consume
information from diverse sources so as I
guess the quote the Eleanor Roosevelt
quote I use in the book is that is that
it's good to learn from other people's
mistakes because you can't live long
enough to make all those mistakes
yourself and although there's an
argument from learning for you from your
own mistakes so to me it's sort of a
balance between the two in and very much
especially over the years I've sort of
developed this notion that that
management is it's a craft and I think I
think medicine is an appropriate
comparison where you can practice the
craft better if you know the best
research but if you haven't done it
there's no way to learn about it by the
way that's one thing I do like about
startups in teaching Stanford a lot of
the suits going to startups is when you
go into a startup you're thrown into
sort of the belly of the beast and you
get to do all this management stuff
there in a big corporation you'd be
protected from and in fact I think that
some of the best employees of big
corporations I'm thinking of like
Facebook which is actually pretty big
and Google and stuff some of the best
managers they have are people who have
sort of like grown that startup and
they'll chafe against the larger
bureaucracy to some extent but they sort
of know what it
to make things worse work so I'm a big
believer that for sort of first job out
of school that start your own business
even if you fail it'll it'll have all
sorts of rewards the rest of your life
in terms of being able to get stuff done
because you actually get practice doing
management type stuff
there's no way that people can could
learn without failing and if you can
show me a situation I would love to see
the situation where just magically you
can parachute in and be instantly lucky
and brilliant and and and you know I
think let's think of some of the heroes
of our day from Steve Jobs to Mark
Zuckerberg and stuff Minh right right
now Zuckerberg is like well a bit of a
darling a bit of an enemy with his Co
Facebook but like they've made enormous
number of mistakes and and I Facebook's
a good example because some of us may
remember a couple years back they had
this thing come out where automatically
if you just went to a restaurant or
anything you did would sort of like show
up on your face or you bought something
it would show up on your Facebook page
and God knows people were probably
buying you know pornography whatever
just sort of like show up on their
Facebook page unless they stopped it
well that those sort of mistakes
actually are part of the process of
learning and it's not gonna bring an
interesting example because although he
although he's a controversial character
he definitely has the guts to try stuff
that might offend people but also sort
of push the envelope but so the argument
that that I've made about failures and
bosses though in some ways to
oversimplify it when I think about
failure there's three general sorts of
responses that emerge from both the
management literature and practice the
first one is what I call the
forgive-and-forget approach and so just
I'm going to see my teenage daughter
after this she's now in college but an
example to forgive and forget'
approaches so the first actually day she
had her learner's permit through a
series of events I still don't
understand
she ran my wife's brand new Infiniti so
it had 300 miles in it into our house
and did $2000 from the damage to the car
and 500 damage of the house in her
reaction was she wanted us to forgive
her and to forget about it and the
problem with forgive and forget is
there's like no accountability and
there's no learning the second approach
is what I call the Silicon Valley
standard this is remember blame
stigmatize ostracize and humiliate and
the problem with that it is that is that
wouldn't you sort of humiliate people or
put them down when they fail you've
failed and they're afraid to admit
mistakes and in the whole world turns
into a cover-your-ass sort of game so no
learning occurs
and the way that the most effective
organizations and in fact if you look at
research on hospitals that learn from
medical mistakes this is the this is
sort of the mantra they sometimes use
it's to forgive and remember so you
forgive to have some psychological
safety and remember so that you can
learn from your own mistakes and other
people's mistakes and the other reason
remember is that if people keep making
the same mistakes over and over again
then there's some accountability and
it's a sign you've kind of got to get
rid of them or having them do something
else but but failure is a complicated
thing and just as a final point about
failure Tom Peters and on down
management theorists I guess including
me have celebrated the virtues of
failure but it's but one thing that I'm
always very careful to say is I don't
like failure I think it sucks it's a
terrible thing I wish it wasn't
necessary but I can't figure out any
other way for people to learn how to do
most things but to sort of screw up
enough till the point where they get
better at it